so here we are at the back bar of the
bellous and every time we do a live star
talk in front of a live audience we try
to create a drink related to the theme
of the evening and tonight we're talking
about solar system exploration we're
going to start off with Mars so I figur
Mars is red the red planet let's get a
red drink going and so we went down the
list of what was red there's like tomato
juice but they don't have much tomato
juice and then they have cranberry juice
but cranberry juice is a little too
transparent
and Mars is not transparent Mars is
Dusty so then we thought well maybe we
can dust it up make it a little opaque
little translucent so you might put some
OJ in it all right so now we have
cranberry OJ and then vodka which I
learned is called aad amadas amadas okay
I didn't I didn't know that cuz I'm a
wine guy all right so so that we said
all right but then what do we call it it
going to be like uh Mar Mars dust then
we thought maybe we should name it after
an actual Mars Landmark Landmark so I
but all the Mars landmarks are in Latin
so one of them we thought maybe Olympus
Mons which translates to Mount Olympus I
thought they was kind of cool but then I
looked at so then I thought Mount
Olympus do we put something on the top
but mountains don't have cherries on the
top they just don't all right so then I
looked over there and there was a lemon
and I said wait a minute if you cut one
edge of the lemon over there and another
Edge over there and you prop it around
the edge like a like the lemon is in a
hot tub with its arms hanging out so we
have a martian
Sunrise that is the drink tonight
excellent and we're going to swap vodka
with rum just
because rum at least in America
represents an exotic place the Caribbean
some place where you don't normally hang
out Mars is most certainly a place where
you don't hang out it is exotic it is
foreign it is a place you want to go one
day and hang out on the shorelines of
the cosmos and so here we are drink to a
martian Sunrise with the sun popping up
cheers